ask Kenny and sha a question uh you can
as a matter of fact Rick of the
year I would I would have to say you
know Chad is playing great but I would
have to still say wanyama because when
he when wanyama is the first option
going by record or going by stats but I
think I think for me by record or going
by stats I'm going by both so I move I
think that chadre because of his Rec the
record and the team he's on he's having
impactful amendments but in terms of
individual talent I still put women Yama
slightly ahead it's a single award we
have this conversation every every MVP
voting Shay GES out the J better be in
the MVP talks but good call has to go
has to go to
Victor okay let to go to Victor you know
team-wise of course you know uh chess
playing on a great team Spurs are not
great but individual is a slight Edge to
statistic and can we ask you this here
here's a thing I'll ask you since you
ask us a question question if you put
wiama on
OKC are they better of
course I like Chad I'm asking you that
we didn't say you in like who you didn't
like I think he he I think they'd be
better cuz he's playing with better
players okay it is so then that's to me
that's that that separated
it OKC again as I said I mean you're
talking about we we just watched two of
the top teams in the Western Conference
record wise m in Oklahoma City and
Minnesota yes who do you like better out
of those
two well I like Minnesota better than
OKC because of Anthony because what you
saw tonight was OKC's got
SGA but uh I I think that that's a good
question but I caught him Ernie no like
good stut I I like it's a good you have
to think about it I probably would go
with
Minnesota uh if if they played each
other because man I tell you what Shay
and Anthony they are the future that's a
great question Ernie but like I say I'm
still I'm still in all on Denver and the
Clippers I would go Minnesota only
because the both teams lack experience
together in the playoffs but at least
you have Conley and Gober who has
experience in the playoffs and I just
think the Minnesota anytime it comes on
to a tiebreaker kind of like that it's
that the Minnesota defense man they
they're solid
they're when they play against a team
like Jaren Jackson didn't have no fear
them them Defenders you like everybody
say got great defense jiren Jackson
didn't care if he hadn't got in foul
trouble he'd have had 40 he was ducking
on them dudes like he was at the YMCA
like he had uh uh I I you know those
guys are big they're great shot blockers
but if you able to move like okay excuse
me like uh Memphis did tonight and shoot
threes you they're going to struggle
well the first time in my 13 12 years
here all you guys are wrong okay see has
a has a better because they they play a
certain way system they use a system
Minnesota is heavily heavily dependent
upon Anthony Edward so you saw we had a
poor first half what if in the post he
has a great first half and a poor second
half OKC everybody touches the ball they
move the ball they play a certain way
and even though SGA is in the MVP
conversation they're not heavily relying
on him so I'm going have to go with a KC
because of the
system